voilà ce débat au sénat mais aussi les
dernières informations en provenance de
l'ukraine au débat tout de suite en
direct avec alain joyandet bonsoir soir
il ya venu vous êtes sénateur et l'ère
de la haute saône membre de la
commission des affaires étrangères de la
défense et des forces armées sylvie
bermann bonsoir bienvenue à vous aussi
ancienne ambassadrice de france en
russie et présidente du conseil
d'administration de l'institut des
hautes études de la défense nationale
patrick martin jonnier bonsoir
professeur à sciences po paris
spécialisé questions européennes et
issac rue pas éditrice politis bonsoir
laetitia alain joyandet je roule on est
juste après ce ce débat au sénat
pourquoi il est important je disais en
titre c'est presque un pied-de-nez à
poutine est ce que vous leur santé comme
ça de surcompensation démocratie oui
c'est un grand consensus c'est assez
rare que du parti communiste jusqu'à
notre groupe nous applaudissions les uns
les autres pour justement condamné cet
acte de guerre envers une démocratie qui
est l'ukraine avec laquelle nous sommes
solidaires je veux dire immédiatement
évidemment notre solidarité avec le
peuple ukrainien mais ça ne doit pas
nous empêcher quand même d'être lucide
de regarder ce qui n'a pas fonctionné
depuis dix ans on approche que les
européens ont eu par rapport à la russie
peut-être en parlerons nous tout à
l'heure je pense que quelque chose a été
manquée la russie a besoin aussi de de
sécurité donc il n'est pas question de
d'absoudre ski dirigeants russes dont on
se posait un certain nombre de questions
sur l'état réel de ses intentions
réelles mais en tout cas cette
condamnation très ferme et cette
solidarité avec l'ukraine doit aussi
nous nous permettent de rester lucide
sur ce qui n'a pas été fait il faut
absolument la désescalade maintenant
parce qu'on ne peut pas non plus faire
une guerre atomique avec les russes on
entendu des propos un peu fou tous et
tous ces temps ci pour un conflit qui
concerne pour l'instant essentiellement
quand même la russie et l'ukraine et on
y revient si vous avez connu
de l'intérieur une période similaire par
exactement évidemment il n'y avait pas
eu cette escalade mais puisque vous
étiez au gouvernement de nicolas sarkozy
quand il ya eu la crise en géorgie et
qu'il était également président de la de
l'union européenne avec la prius moment
jusqu'au quai traits parallèles avec
aujourd'hui pour des raisons d'ailleurs
un peu similaire de d'une partie du
territoire qui qui qui échappait à la
géorgie au profit de la russie et avec
le président sarkozy qui présidait aussi
l'europe à ce moment là nous avons
réussi à obtenir un retrait de 2,2
poutine à ce moment là mais en faisant
quelques promesses qui n'ont peut-être
pas totalement été écrites notamment sur
l'élargissement de l'otan on ne peut pas
non plus laisser l'otan se rapprocher
trop de la russie on peut comprendre un
moment donné que poutine a eu peur ce
qui n'excuse pas son son geste
d'aujourd'hui bien évidemment là bien
complet je pense qu'il faut laisser
s'isoler d'une certaine façon c'est ce
que j'entends un peu dans vos propos
bien sûr je pense qu'on l'a même isolé
le le fait que l'otan avant c'est que
petit à petit on grapille avec l'otan
pour se rapprocher de plus en plus des
frontières russes quelque chose qui ne
rassure pas la russie qui a besoin sa
sécurité et n'oublions pas que au moment
de delà de la fin de l'empiré soviétique
la russie était à genoux aujourd'hui
elle est quand même un peu un peu mieux
qu'à cette époque là elle a donc envie
de deux aujourd'hui de regarder la
question d'une manière très différente
et donc je pense que ça doit nous nous
appeler pour l'avenir d'abord il faut
vraiment appeler la désescalade je
n'entends personne demandé la
désescalade c'est très inquiétant mais
on y reviendra évidemment si lieberman
vous vous étiez en poste à moscou ou
encore quoi de trois ans et ça oui
est-ce que vous avez c'est très
difficile tout le monde veut rentrer
dans la tête de vladimir poutine et
personne ne le peut mais est ce que vous
avez senti évoluer le président russe
justement par rapport à ce que ce que
nous décrit à l'instant alain joyandet
ce sentiment d'isolement et où est ce
que de toute façon il avait en tête
ce plan de grignoter petit à petit sur
l'ukraine en tout cas l'homme qu'on ait
vu dans son conseil national de sécurité
n'est pas celui qu'on a rencontrés à
l'époque où j'étais à moscou le
président de la république lui-même en
rentrant de sa mission a dit ce n'est
plus le même homme est ce que je pense
c'est de toute façon depuis des années
effectivement il a cette obsession se
soucie de revanche par rapport aux
occidentaux parce qu'il a le sentiment
qu'une promesse enfin une promesse a été
faite de nom élargissement de l'otan aux
frontières et donc il a toujours
considéré que c'était une trahison ça
c'est sa première obsession la deuxième
c'est par rapport à l'ukraine c'est à
dire qu officier du kgb au moment où de
la chute de l'union soviétique
c'est son monde qui s'est effondré et il
n'a pas compris que cette république qui
était avant le parti de l'union
soviétique et qui était non seulement le
grenier à blé mais il y avait les
mineurs du donbass c'est quelque chose
qu'il n'a jamais admis donc je pense que
ce qui s'est passé là aussi c'est que
pendant les deux ans de vide dont il
avait très peur il s'est enfermé il se
bunkériser ils ne rencontraient plus les
personnalités étrangères ils ne
rencontraient plus même ses propres
collaborateurs puisqu'il laissait cette
distance énorme donc il y avait plus
véritablement d'échangés il s'est dit ça
c'était intéressant de se passer à
l'acte le syndrome de tous les
dictateurs qu'ils finissent par se
s'isoler de plus en plus c'est pas avoir
une peur principal qu'il a peur
médical sanitaire c'est quand même très
intéressant c'est la même chose pour
staline qui vivait entouré d'infirmière
à la fin de la fin de sa vie est-ce que
vous faisais part au pardon parce que
cette question je sais que vous pouvez
pas y répondre mais ce que vous le
décrivez c'est quand même une dérive
risques psychologiques c'est un peu une
dérive et c'est ce que disent beaucoup
de russes d'ailleurs et comme il est
difficile vous disiez dans la tête de
poutine beaucoup de gens de l'entourage
de poutine disait que c'était une boîte
noire c'est à dire qu'on ne sait pas ce
qu'il y a dans sa tête on le sait le
jour où il a décidé et là ni les russes
ni les ukrainiens jusqu'au dernier jour
n'imaginait une seule seconde qu'il
allait envahir la totalité de l'ukraine
peut-être le donbass mais pas la
totalité l'ukraine et pas bombarder kiev
et pourtant il est un texte de vladimir
poutine qui l'a écrit en juillet et qui
est disponible sur le site du kremlin et
sur le site de l'ambassade russe où il
décrit point par point son obsession et
son projet donc il y a quand même un
texte qui existent vous voyez quelques
mois auparavant et il y avait aussi les
renseignements américains qui
visiblement avait les bonnes
informations puisqu'il ne sais c'est
d'alerter sur une possible entrée en
action des russes donc on a aussi
peut-être côté occidental a voulu voir
ce qu'il pouvait arriver alors c'est pas
seulement du côté occidental ces
quelques jours avant l'invasion le
ministre ukrainien de la défense disait
qu'il n'y aurait pas d'invasion le chef
fait que l'ukraine est bon le ceva les
vandales aujourd'hui c'est pas ça oui
non mais parce que en fait poutine
n'avait rien à retirer de cette
intervention et on le voit aujourd'hui
c'est pas c'est pas un succès il valait
mans une évolution des opinions
publiques alors en ukraine c'est clair
aujourd'hui ici il y avait des
russophones qui était plutôt pro-russe
aujourd'hui c'est terminé il ya une
véritable identité nationale le chef de
l'état qui était le méprise est détesté
par poutine est aujourd'hui ovationné au
parlement européen et dans le monde
entier et là on est soudés comme
il change de pied sur sa politique de
défense et la suisse sourit enfin bon on
pourrait faire une liste très très
longue de ce que sans doute personne
n'avait prévu et peut-être vadimir
poutine non plus je vous redonne la
parole dans un instant pardon mais il ya
un élément qui est quand même très
important patrick martin geniez dont on
n'a pas encore parlé c'est le droit des
peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes c'est à
dire que dans cette histoire il y a il
ya quand même parce que vous parliez de
la responsabilité de l'otan mais il ya
quand même un pays l'ukraine un
président élu et un peuple ukrainien qui
veut depuis des années manifestement
s'ancrer plus dans la démocratie et à
l'ouest que vers la russie ah mais vous
avez tout à fait raison on entend ces
derniers temps alors on parle de la
sécurité de la russie on parle les états
unis vont négocier avec la russie on
parle des négociations entre les pays
européens et la russie est là dedans on
oublie qu'il ya un président ukrainien
une ukraine libre et indépendante
effectivement on a l'impression qu'on
passe largement au dessus des règles du
droit international vous l'avez dit le
droit à l'autodétermination des peuples
ce qui ne veut pas dire qu'il fallait
pas négocier quelque chose sur la crim
sur le don basse mais pas avec des
pistolet sur la tempe n'est ce pas il
existe des référendums démocratique
c'est pour ça on dit tout le monde dira
les accords de minsk n'ont jamais été
appliquées c'est à dire une plus grande
autonomie pour le donbass par exemple
mais on sait très bien que l'autonomie
du donbass pour l'adie mur poutine
s'était carrément une indépendance et m
finalement le grappin sur l'ukraine et
donc vous avez raison il ya des
résolutions des nations-unies il y a un
droit international le droit à
l'indépendance à l'intégrité est
aujourd'hui ah oui il faut faire la
désescalade il faut négocier avec la
veille de vladimir poutine mais négocier
sur quoi les deux délégations ne se sont
pas entendus
volà de menace qui s'est dit prêt à
négocier mais négocier quoi vous ne
négociez pas en disant on va dépasser
l'ukraine c'est à dire qu'on va négocier
avec la russie éventuellement une
autonomie de la crimée qui est déjà
acquise d'ailleurs le détachement du
dombass et puis finalement on pourrait
départager du cred au niveau du fleuve
au milieu le mièvre il en est hors de
question il y a un président qui était
il est elle est élue démocratiquement
avec plus de 70% des voix par conséquent
c'est à lui à son peuple et au parlement
précisément de décider ce que doit être
l'avenir de ce pays ce n'est pas aux
grandes puissances telles yalta au
lendemain de la seconde guerre mondiale
pour se départager précisément api et 6
à l'onu le droit à l'autodétermination
le droit à la démocratie est donc
aujourd'hui c'est le sens de l'appel au
secours de vos lots de rs qui ce matin
au parlement européen il a dit moi j'ai
pris conscience finalement que je n'irai
pas au sein de l'otan je ne durerait pas
longtemps puisque personne ne le
finalement mais je lance une bouée de
sauvetage je veux mon ancrage à l'union
européenne parce que vous êtes la
liberté vous êtes la démocratie sauf que
sauf que si je peux me permettre un mot
il n'y a pas de procédure d'urgence
profondeur dans la procédure d'urgence
on peut lancer la
procession que il me semble que le seul
fait de lancer la procédure va remettre
encore de l'huile sur le feu et en tout
cas c'est ma position il ya une lueur
plusieurs positions à défendre mais il
me semble que même si et bien évidemment
qui a le droit des peuples à disposer
d'eux mêmes on peut quand même regarder
ce qui s'est passé qui peut expliquer
pourquoi poutine a eu cette attitude
regardez ce qui s'est passé non plus
depuis 10 ans quand à un moment donné
déjà des en 2008 on disait qu'il fallait
que l'ukraine rentrer dans l'otan
c'était déjà une provocation pour
poutine donc moi je crois que j'ai on
essaie tous de comprendre je crois que
petit à petit menaces après menace de
rapprochement de l'otan je pense que
poutine petit à petit a préparé son coup
et comme il le fait d'ailleurs en
géorgie et je pense que le coup était
prêt depuis très longtemps on voit ton
vaut bien même si sa voix un peu moins
vite qu'il le souhaite on voit qu'il
était prêt depuis longtemps sauf que
l'union européenne c'est pas le temps et
que hélas juin un accord d'association
ont été signés en 2017 qui permettait
d'engager une première un premier pas
vers l'adhésion est ce qu'il demandait
aujourd'hui par vélo devient celle à ce
qui ce n'est pas une procédure accélérée
qui en effet n'existe pas c'est un geste
politique
on demande aujourd'hui aux instances
européennes notamment conseil européen
qui va se réunir au mois de mars un
geste pour la politique pour dire oui
nous allons rapidement vous donner le
statut de candidat parce que si demain
le président ukrainien et renversés et
il ya des chances qu'il ne soit ça va
être balayé
éviter l' escalade tout en résistant à
poutine on voit bien qu'on est sur une
ligne de crête laetitia et c'est l'une
des images fortes de cette journée
cette guerre économique
annoncée décrétée par bruno le maire et
on se rend compte que évidemment tous
les mots prononcés par
l'exécutif ont un poids diplomatique
considérable il a dû revenir sur sur
cette phrase qu'il avait prononcée
c'était ce matin sur france info donc à
cette formule la guerre économique c'est
un cas d'école un communication
politique comme en un mot lâché dans une
interview le matin rebondi quasiment
immédiatement sur la scène
internationale et il force le ministre à
faire marche arrière et perturbe la
diplomatie thomas on va regarder et on
va ré écouter ce qu'a dit bruno le maire
ce matin sur france info il était
visiblement très en forme et alors son
cabinet m'a expliqué avant de regarder
l'extrait qu'il était déterminé à
montrer que la france était à la pointe
sur le sujet des sanctions économiques
on regarde c'est la russie qui va
souffrir c'est l'économie russe qui va
souffrir et c'est le système financier
russe qui va s'effondrer sous nos yeux
l'europe elle la seule conséquence
qu'elle peut avoir dans les semaines qui
viennent c'est une petite augmentation
des prix en fonction de l'augmentation
des prêts l'énergie willy sanctions sont
efficaces les sanctions économiques et
financières sont même d'une efficacité
redoutable et je veux laisser planer
aucune ambiguïté
sur la détermination européenne sur ce
sujet nous allons livrer une guerre
économique et financière totale à la
russie
voilà le mot guerre bien sûr à poser
problème bien qu'ils soient accompagnés
de économique et financière et c'est ce
qu'a fait remarquer bruno le maire quand
il est sorti du studio car son entourage
immédiatement lui a fait remarquer que
quand même ce mot était peut-être un peu
risqué lui a dit mais non mais j'ai dit
économique et financière mais il a
compris lui même un à la réaction de ses
proches qu'il avait certainement a été
trop loin et donc sur cnn quelques
minutes plus tard il fait une interview
il décide de ne pas agréer employer ce
mot sauf que sur twitter et les restos
les réseaux sociaux la polémique est
partie alors bien sûr l'opposition s'en
empare on est je vous rappelle à moins
de deux mois du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle dont bien sûr
des créneaux opportunité aussi belle que
celle là on la saisit mais il ya surtout
dmitri medvedev qui est l'ancien
président russe qui est aujourd'hui le
président le vice-président du conseil
de sécurité de la russie qui réagit via
un tweet qu'il écrit en anglais et en
français où il dit un ministre français
a dit aujourd'hui qui nous avait déclaré
la guerre économique fait attention à
votre discours messieurs et n'oubliez
pas que les guerres économiques de
l'histoire de l'humanité se sont souvent
transformé en guerre réelle c'est ce qui
se passe après à partir de là bercy
alors on ne sait pas si c'est bercy
matignon ou l'elysée décide de
rétropédaler d'envoyer un communiqué l
afp où on récuse finalement le terme de
guerre parce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure qu'il n'y avait pas le mot d
escalade mais bercy le site parce que la
stratégie c'est la désescalade et alors
l'entourage de bruno le maire m'a aussi
expliqué que celui qui parlait
directement à boot inn et à zellers qui
s'était manuel macro alors ça sent quand
même un peu le coup de fil de l'elysée
entre vous et moi mais surtout que en
fait le mot guerre allait aller contre
de la stratégie française qui était de
désigner uniquement vladimir poutine
comme l'agresseur c'est surtout ça parce
que finalement ce que des grosses
sanctions très importante majeur que
fait l'union européenne excusez moi mais
c'est bien de bien et bien une guerre
économique et financière on vient
d'apprendre que la compagnie dans scream
2 vient de faire faillite et que cette
nouvelle banque ont été exclus du
système de paiement international
véritablement c'est une guerre
économique et financière mais je suis
d'accord avec vous pour dire c'est
contraire peut-être à la stratégie du
président la république qui veut encore
ouvrir une voie pour la diplomatie oui
et puis c'était moi je trouve
contradictoire avec un message qui était
diffusée du président de la république
aux soldats français pratiquement au
même moment fois leur disant vous allez
être engagée vous je vous demande de
faire preuve de prudence de retenues
s'étaient leterme devait tout ado
retenue je voudrais juste un mois
peut-être sur medvedev que c'est lui qui
répond à un bruno le maire quel rôle il
joue quel poids il a aujourd'hui en
russie parce qu'on cherche qui est un
contrepoids éventuellement face à
poutine non il a un poids relativement
mieux limité était premier ministre et
finalement
poutine lui a trouvé un successeur mais
on ne sait jamais ça en tout cas
medvedev était venu à paris il avait été
reçu par edouard philippe ça s'était
très bien passé c'est quelqu'un qui est
plutôt lui ouvert sur l'occident mais ça
ne l'a pas empêché parce qu'il n'a pas
le choix de dire que le moment était
venu de rompre les relations avec le
monde occidental et que la russie n'en
avait pas besoin mais c'est vrai que sur
le terme de guerre le problème même si
c'est aux financières économiques on ne
souhaite pas faire la guerre au peuple
russe on souhaite viser le responsable
et les responsables de cette attaque et
le but de sanction n'est pas de punir
mais d'essayer de faire changer la
position et de conduire un moment donné
effectivement un accord sur sur le est
vu l'ampleur des sanctions économiques
le peuple russe warrants et en souffrir
étaient bien sûr vivants souffrir oui
mais quand vous regardez que les
sondages soient disant même pas des
médias indépendants estime que 60% de la
population russe estime que son chef
suprême a raison bin hammam a donné il
faut assumer c'est comme lorsqu'on a
parlé de ce sondage en russie on a joué
jusqu'à présent
deux d'ailleurs de médias des prénoms
ont été voilà refermer
même en me donner lorsque vous y êtes
vous on est au pouvoir viktor orban est
bien et avec une majorité absolue faut
assumer de la même façon que lorsqu'on a
eu beau rue johnson problem is
britannique est bien fallait assumer le
bric site donc à un moment donné voilà
sauf qu'ici en russie on est dans une
dictature et qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien
que il ya quand même des personnes
notamment les jeunes en russie qui
manifestent et qui ne sont pas
nécessairement d'accord avec la démarche
lui a déjà un millier d'arrestations
voilà les manifestes et qui se font
arrêter parce que ces donjons réussi
donc c'est plus difficile pour certains
de prendre position clairement le
rédacteur en chef de certains journaux
l'ont fait courageusement et en
ukrainien en plus mais tout le monde ne
peut pas le faire non plus alain
joyandet peut-être une réaction à cette
valse à trois temps de de bruno le maire
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'était une
erreur d'employer ces termes la soeur en
tout cas c'est la deuxième parce que
quelques jours avant il avait parlé d'
armes atomiques financièrement parlant
de la sortie du réseau switch a pris fin
à tout prix switch armes atomiques
financière donc je pense que il était
très guerrier cette semaine bon voilà
c'est un excès de langage pense kiki qui
symbolisait à toute la détermination du
gouvernement et de l'est de l'europe à
apprendre c'est apprendre ces sanctions
mais j'aurais juste revenir un instant
sur la question de la désescalade est la
négociation parce que quand une fois
qu'on a dit tout ça même si elle droit
des peuples à disposer d'eux mêmes il ya
bien un moment le seul problème c'est de
savoir quand mais il ya quand même bien
un moment où il va y avoir une
diplomatie qui va se mettre en route
d'une manière je serai avec vous mais ya
aussi un moment où il faut mais il faut
stopper
phase c'est-à-dire la phase de
l'établissement du rapport de force on
est là dedans pour l'instant c'est la
guerre voilà massacre ce sont des crimes
de guerre si ça ce n'est pas acceptable
mais si le professeur la cour pénale
internationale se réunit bien sûr parler
des crimes de guerre bien sûr mais ça
c'est le jeu et des criminels c'est ce
que je vous ai dit tout à l'heure et le
parlement et unanimes là-dessus oui bien
serment unanime nous sommes unanimes et
malgré cela et malgré ça parce que ça se
terminera forcément comme ça il ya un
moment donné où il y aura forcément des
discussions une diplomatie des
négociations il faudra bien en sortir il
faut quand même laissé un espoir à nos
concitoyens pas qu'en france mais comme
laisser un espoir sur une éventuelle
négociation dure on peut pas rester
comme ça dans la guerre on va pas
augmenter
il ya un débat qui est intéressant
autour de la décision européenne de
donner des armes à l'ukraine au
parlement à l'assemblée pardon en début
d'après midi dans la même configuration
qu'au sénat jean luc mélenchon a pris la
parole pour répondre aux premiers 10
jean castex en disant qu'il était opposé
à la vente d'armes à l'ukraine par
l'europe il a été conspué quasi hué par
les députés est-ce qu'il faut vendre des
armes donner des armes à l'ukraine dont
je vais vous savez que le gouvernent
nous avons eu c'est un signe d' escalade
ou pas pour vous par exemple pour voir
des coraux pour moi c'est un signe d'
escalade mais d'ailleurs jeu on a eu la
confirmation sans trahir le le secret
d'une réunion à huis clos que nous avons
eue avec le directeur de cabinet de la
ministre de la défense on voit bien
qu'il ya quand même une certaine crainte
a livré des armes
à l'ukraine puisque ces armes livré à
l'ukraine peuvent aussi tomber dans la
main des adversaires de l'ukraine
imaginer que l'ukraine soit totalement
envahie et que poutine réussi son coup
si on donne des armes aux ukrainiens qui
va les récupérer donc vous voyez bien
que tout ça on est en une fois de plus
thomas hugues sur le le chemin de crête
je suis encore à relier sied vraiment
facile je l'aurais version de la vérité
très compliqué sanaa dans un moment très
compliqué aussi bien pour le
gouvernement français que point que pour
nos diplomates madame l'ambassadrice
vous connaissez ça par coeur mais il
faudra bien sortir alors c'est aussi une
cyberguerre et pour en parler je vous
propose de rejoindre tout de suite avec
nous en duplex en visioconférence louis
betinho qu'est cherche chercheur au
centre géode
bonsoir vous êtes spécialiste du
cyberespace russe
déjà est ce que cette guerre sur le
terrain elle se double de cyber attaque
est ce qu'elles ont été détectés
répertoriés depuis le début de la
semaine ou même avant que l'offensive
terrestre et aérienne le débat alors les
cyberattaques ont été assez nombreuses
elles ont eu lieu à la fois avant et
pendant
l ont commencé dès janvier enfin on peut
dire qu'elles vont commencer dès 2014 de
fait puisque dès la révolution du maiden
de l'euro maïdan en 2014 le nombre de
cyber attaques attribuées aux russes en
2015 et une des attaques très nombreuses
sur dès 2016 et cdd à globo y compris
sur des cibles à ces nouvelles comme
l'infrastructure électrique de l'ukraine
et depuis 2002 puis lé 2022 et début
d'année on voit une augmentation des
cyber-attaques de diverses type que ce
soit des attaques en déni de service qui
consistent à envoyer de trop de trafic
sur un site pour un serveur et à faire
tomber les les sites en question que ce
soit des attaques de dab wiper qui sont
des des attaques visant à effacer des
systèmes informatiques entier ou encore
d'autres types d' attaques contre le
site notamment en vue du journal en
ligne qui poste quitte à un grand
journal anglophone du créneau phone de
kiev et donc d'être un peu une
multiplication de choses comme ça qui se
déroule en ce moment est ce qu'il ya une
force
de réponse en ukraine et peut-être on
sait que ça existe aussi dans cet
univers
des hackers d'autres pays qui viennent
défendre l'ukraine est ce que ça existe
ça oui il faut préciser que toutes les
évêques ne sont pas attribués
directement à la russie d'abord c'est
pas forcément simple des tribunes
cyberattaques
techniquement c'est possible
politiquement c'est un acte qui dit
quelque chose quand même donc elsa qui
ont été attribués par différents
secteurs soit au russe mais aussi aux
biélorusses et donc effectivement on
pose la question des acteurs extérieurs
et nous aussi le fait que les acteurs ne
seront pas forcément directement liée à
l'état russe c'est un autre niveau
d'attribution que de dire que tel cyber
attaque vient d'un acteur d'un tel pays
ou qui dit un acteur liés à l'êta ou
encore dans un état lui-même ce sont des
choses différentes en ce qui concerne la
les répliques éventuelle de l'ukraine
pour l'instant le porte qui se concentre
surtout sur la cyber défense et donc sur
la gestion de leur système d'information
je sais qu'il ya eu quand même quelques
éléments qui sont venus renforcer cette
cyber défense que sont notamment la
larrabee de response force de l'otan qui
sont d'un groupement de plusieurs
experts de ces îles européens qui sont
venus aider pour la première fois c'est
la première fois que cet accord sont
réunis il est opérationnel qui sont
venues des gouvernements un créneau
récemment rester avec nous à ce jour
donnera la parole dans un instant il ya
donc sept cet aspect là qu'on n'avait
pas encore abordé sur ce plateau et il
faut que c'est vraiment une dimension
intéressante aussi de ce conflit et puis
à la guerre de l'information qui elle a
été beaucoup plus médiatisé ça a été
confirmé ce soir un l'europe a décidé
d'interdire
deux chaînes financées par la russie rt
le château des explique nick est ce
qu'il faut est-ce qu'il fallait
interdire ces chaînes je vais pas non
moi je suis je ne suis pas du tout sur
cette ligne je pense que au contraire
dans un pays comme la france où puisque
ça va se passer aussi en france on parle
de l'europe je pense qu'il faut laisser
la liberté d'expression même si elle
nous gêne ou moins la contradiction et
là on va prendre des méthodes d'un des
fausses informations par deux roues même
si ce sont des fausses informations vous
savez les fausses informations sur les
réseaux sociaux est ce qu'on coupe les
réseaux sociaux donc moi je pense qu'il
faut laisser des gens c'est que les
mêmes responsabilités dès aujourd'hui
quand je viens aux frimas j'ai bien
compris mais si on emploie les mêmes
méthodes que celles que nous dénonçons
justement en en russie de la même
manière je pense qu'il faut pas aller
trop loin non plus je sais bien qu'en ce
moment tout le monde et tout le monde
est vraiment jusqu'au boutiste 1 mais
l'équipe de foot et la coupe du monde
les artistes
est-ce qu'on va fermer toutes les
institutions russes en europe qu'elle
soit cultuelle culturel on sent que là
on est on est un peu à la limite on est
un peu la limite les sanctions
économiques
les sanctions 1000e l'action militaire
et tout ça mais mais tout le reste tout
le reste qui est autour parce que cette
guerre elle va peut-être pas non plus
durer pendant des mois et des mois en
tout cas c'est mon avis je n'engage pas
mon groupe c'est mon avis personnel je
pense que le sport ça toujours été un
élément d'amitié entre les peuples et
peut-être que en laissant les russes
aller à la coupe du monde ne se
questionne aussi un élément de soft
power que poutine a beaucoup utilisé et
on sait que ça le fola aussi de
d'interdire par exemple l'équipe de
football de russie qui va pas pouvoir
participer aux barrages d'accès à la cnu
oui si on les avait fait en russie est
la ville du monde gagnée par la france
en russie bref il faut espérer que ce
soit que provisoire mais j'ai cru
comprendre que les chefs d'état
gouvernement avait décidé l'envoi pas
prononcer le terme de guerre mais de
faire de cet état un état paria paria à
tous les niveaux l'économique financier
mais également culturel et sportif c'est
peut-être les tables j'en sais rien mais
est ce que ça peut faire reculer
effectivement donc le choisir les
oligarques du régime tous les gens qui
pensent que finalement vous l'avez libya
poutine excusez moi mais n'a plus toute
sa raison et que ça pourrait entraîner
des règlements de compte en étant
optimiste au sein du kremlin je crois
que la situation n'est que provisoire
dès lors qu on n'acceptera aucune issue
diplomatique par le haut et qu'on
respecte de nouveaux l'intégrité
territoriale alors les relations
pourront reprendre sur un bon pied mais
pour l'instant il n'y a pas cette
situation vous avez vu des artistes vous
avez eu deux oligarques dire c'est très
bien ce que fait vladimir poutine donc
un moment donné ça suffit à un taux
qu'il faut dire faut que chacun assume
ses responsabilités c'est comme j'ai vu
monsieur abramovitch bas à londres dire
il a écrit à ses employés en disant je
suis pas tellement content avec ce que
fait monsieur vladimir poutine alors que
l'on sait que c'était un soutien du
régime pendant longtemps donc
aujourd'hui faut que chacun assume ses
responsabilités et si la situation est
normalisée d'ici deux mois d'accord
pourra revoir les choses mais il faut
aussi une totale solidarité entre les
pays de l'union européenne sylvie
bermann phrase de conclusion dans cette
première partie 2 le débat s comment
vous est ce que vous pensez que vladimir
poutine sort affaibli ou pas de cette
première semaine de guerre de notre
point de vue il sort incontestablement
affaibli puisque non seulement il n'a
pas obtenu ces buttes de guerre mais au
contraire serre qui l'a amené une action
qui à l'encontre des intérêts de la
russie pendant longtemps il a été jugé
comme un homme du rhin autoritaire un
dictateur tout ce que vous voulez mais
ce qu'il ne faisait il le faisait pour
rendre son rang à la russie est
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas ce qui se passe
donc
à la fois sur le plan international et
je pense aussi en interne je pense qu'il
ya effectivement ces sondages qui font
apparaître qu'il ya une majorité de la
population qui est favorable mais parce
qu'ils n'ont pas le choix de
l'information non plus mais de plus en
plus des jeunes des journalistes des
scientifiques aussi le
condamnant tout casser les ce passage à
l'acte merci beaucoup merci à tous les
trois d'avoir participé à ce débat ici
en plateau merci également à louper
signaux pour son expertise sur la
cyberguerre en russie notre édition
spéciale continue avec de nouveaux
invités on va voir quelle image quelle
information on peut retenir de cette
sixième journée de guerre justement les
faits majeurs retenus par samia de sheer
tout de suite
les chaînes de télévisions ukrainiennes
ont cessé d'émettre cet après midi une
frappe de l'armée russe a touché la tour
de transmission de kiev tuant au moins
cinq personnes un peu plus tôt moscou
elle est appelée à l'évacuation des
civils vivant à proximité des sites de
renseignement l'étau se resserre autour
de la capitale ukrainienne la nuit
dernière un convoi russe long de plus de
60 km ha été observés par satellite à 25
km de la ville
s'adressant aux dirigeants européens par
visioconférence
le président ukrainien à redemander une
intégration d'urgence de l'ukraine à
l'union européenne
sans jouer l'ukraine sera seul
nous avons prouvé notre force nous avons
montré que nous sommes vos égaux
donc prouver que vous êtes avec nous et
que vous n'allez pas nous laisser tomber
moscou semble vouloir passer à la
vitesse supérieure à kharkiv deuxième
ville du pays un bombardement sur la
préfecture a fait au moins dix morts
selon l'ukraine qui accuse la russie de
crimes de guerre moscou de son côté
assure ne pas viser les civils et reste
déterminé à s'emparer du territoire
ukrainien
les forces armées russes continueront à
mener l'opération militaire spéciale
jusqu'à ce que tous les objectifs fixés
soient atteints
d'après l'onu le conflit a déjà fait
plus d'un million de déplacés à
l'intérieur du pays six cent mille
autres personnes ont fui le territoire
et les files d'attentes est encore
longue à la frontière polonaise où des
ressortissants de pays étrangers vivant
en ukraine disent être refoulé en raison
de leur origine
notre débat continue je vous présente
mais invité jean yves le conte bonsoir
vous êtes sénateur socialiste des
français établis hors de france gagnée
ackermann bonsoir nous devons trouver
historienne journaliste spécialiste de
la russie l'espace postsoviétique votre
livre le régiment immortel la guerre
sacrée de poutine c'est aux éditions
premier parallèle frédéric encel bonsoir
merci d'être là docteur en géopolitique
maître de conférences à sciences po
paris et votre livre les voies de la
puissance sort ce mercredi aux éditions
odile jacob laetitia cru pas été
politique qui est resté à mes côtés je
commence avec vos ans j'ai rejoint les
bleus comptent peut-être pour prendre
des nouvelles des français qui vivent en
ukraine c'est vrai que ils sont combien
d'abord et est ce qu'on sait où ils sont
comment s'occupe d'eux
ils sont aujourd'hui à peu près 1000
sur le territoire de l'ukraine de
grosses difficultés pour pour pour pour
sortir du pays en particulier compte
tenu des queues aux hauts postes
frontières
et puis et puis finalement la crise n'a
pas été correctement anticipée c'est à
dire la crise n'a pas été correctement
anticipée servent d'abord personne n'a
vraiment cru qu'on allait arriver à ça
oui bon
et puis moi j'y étais il ya deux
semaines
finalement beaucoup d'effets beaucoup de
français c'est ma vie est là je reste
parce qu'on n'imaginait pas
de poutine puisse aller au delà du
combat puis puis puis piqué va siéger
avec eux avec tout ce que ça peut
vouloir dire en termes de conditions de
vie tous les jours d'approvisionnement
de risque pour sa vie voilà donc
mais un sentiment depuis lire d'abord
don et je dirais même de négligence des
pouvoirs publics
le pr le ministre affaires étrangères
qui doutaient barre les russes nous ont
dit que la voix du sud était ouverte
donc vous pourrez tenter sous votre
responsabilité
et puis on insiste on assiste enfin moi
j'avais posé une question d'actualité la
semaine dernière sur le sujet
gouvernement répond oui on veut on
appris en mesure les besoins de ceux qui
ne peuvent pas qu'ils sont pas autonomes
parce qu'ils n'ont pas les moyens parce
qu'ils n'ont pas de voiture etc le midi
libre a coûté c'est comme ça dont il y
en a qui doivent payer 1500 2000 euros
pour avoir une voiture pour les andes et
à la frontière il ya plus de google il
ya plus il ya plus les panneaux donc que
quelqu'un qui connaît pas bien le pays i
enfin sur la route il pourra rien faire
mais même si rencontre personne de
dangereux
et puis il fallait faire et puis et puis
alors la révolte absolue la révolte
absolue contre c'est quand vous demandez
à ce qu'il ya un petit convoi pour ceux
qui sont pas autonomes parce que je
crois que le centre de crise a quand
même fait un suivi individualisé des
gens avec les situations donc on sait ce
qu'ils ne sont pas autonomes
et d'apprendre comme ça que le
l'ambassadeur passe de cleval vie sans
même que on emmène avec soit ceux qui
ont servi dans les écoles françaises et
où ce conte a identifié comme étant
pas en mesure de bouger seul
c'est quand même très problématique
voilà et puis après je n'ai suivi
quelques-uns qui attendait c'est quelque
fois des jours de chaos au
poste-frontière aujourd'hui même quand
vous êtes à vif
c'est mieux d'aller passer dans la
roumanie où il ya moins que que de
l'apologue
bon merci pour ces pour ces informations
c'est pas le coeur du débat mais c'est
quand même une situation que le match
est très problématique et je voulais
vous entendre là dessus fabricant sel
dans votre livre vous parlez de la
russie comme d'une puissance pauvres et
même très pauvre j'ai été frappé par ce
pas par cette citation est ce qu'elle a
les moyens de cette guerre la russie
alors elle en a les moyens dans une
certaine mesure je veux dire par là que
une grande puissance pauvre n'a par
définition pas les moyens dont disposent
aujourd'hui l'europe qui n'est pas
encore une puissance globale date
qu'elle le deviendra grâce à monsieur
poutine enfin mais comme les états unis
et les états unis dispose non seulement
d'un droit de veto au conseil de
sécurité dispose de l'armé atomique
autrement dit les deux jokers dont
dispose aussi la russie mais a réussi
par ailleurs pardonnez-moi de filer la
métaphore du jeu de cartes pour le reste
un peu d2 d3 d4 alors que les états unis
grandes puissances riches la chine sans
doute demain disposera de toute une
palette qui lui permettra d'éviter de
mettre systématiquement ses jokers et
notamment la bombe parce que là vous
renverser la table donc ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire qu'une grande
puissance pauvres hélas les moyens de
cette politique parce que outre les
chars qui entre parenthèses sont pas
tous de très bonne qualité quant aux
équipements des soldats c'est le moins
qu'on puisse dire on n'a pas affaire à
une armée très moderne elle vous envoie
elle vous empoisonne les strips des
opposants à l'étranger et voir d'autres
personnalités demain elle utilise des
cyberattaques c'est pas extrêmement cher
et l'utilisent wagner c'est à dire des
groupes de mercenaires qu'elle n'assume
d'ailleurs pas réellement sur un
syndrome de théâtre d'opérations jusque
et y compris à bangui en centrafrique
sa venue signifie quoi ça signifie que
on joue sur des choses qui peuvent sur
des éléments constitutifs de la
puissance qui peuvent nous gênait pas
gêner les adversaires considérablement
mais sans sens utile va sans pouvoir
utiliser larmes qui aujourd'hui est
quand même l'une des plus efficaces au
monde c'est à dire larmes économiques
technologiques et financières donc il de
cette bière oui mais les moyens de la
remporter c'est à dire d'être sûr de la
gagner la réponse est non et la réponse
est non et je le dis d'une phrase parce
que de manière agréablement stupéfiante
et bien l'union européenne et au delà un
certain nombre de pays la plupart en
fait des pays du monde jusque et y
compris la chine qui s'est abstenu qui
n'a pas soutenu la russie et qui
aujourd'hui dont aujourd'hui le chef de
l'état s'est entretenu avec le chef de
l'état ukrainien
ont manifestement monsieur poutine a
mésestimé ou a surestimé sa capacité de
l'emporter rapidement lui qui est à la
tête seulement donc d'une grande
puissance pauvres galia ackerman est-ce
que venir poutine est plus isolé après
cette première semaine de conflit que
qu'avant qu'avant l'invasion de
l'ukraine
tu es certainement puisque personne en
fait ne croyez donc c'était invasion et
avait la concentration énorme de troupes
pratiquement la l'encerclement de
l'ukraine par les troupes russes depuis
le nord depuis la biélorussie et sur
tout le pourtour jusqu'à odessa
avec une concentration de troupes aussi
un crime bien sûr mais tout le monde
croyez que voilà il lance des ultimatums
a le temps aux états unis et que cette
concentration de troupes ne sert qu'à
cela et donc vous avez vu tous les
ballets diplomatiques on a essayé de
négocier avec lui alors que toutes les
décisions ont été prises en fait et je
pense maintenant qu'il a posé ses
ultimatums d'emblée impossibles à
satisfaire ses exigences
justement pour
avoir une justification d'une guerre
totale contre le crâne et peut-être à
l'avenir pas seulement l'ukraine voilà
ce que je vous propose d'en entendre
plusieurs fois le président ukrainien
dans ce dans cette partie de notre débat
volodymyr zelensky qui était en
visioconférence reçu en quelque sorte au
parlement européen écouter ce premier
extrait où il parle
de bombardement sur la place centrale de
la ville de kharkiv
le bombardement de la place centrale de
kharkiv est une terreur flagrante ou non
dissimulé personne ne pardonnera
personne n'oubliera cette trappe contre
kharkiv est un crime de guerre c'est du
terrorisme d'état de la part de la
fédération de russie après cela la
russie est manifestement en état
terroriste et doit l'être officiellement
des crimes de guerre c'est ce que les
opinions publiques de nos pays
démocratiques voix galia ackerman mais
les russes qu'est ce qu'ils voient les
russes à la télévision en ce moment ben
ça c'est très intéressant parce que
justement ces derniers jours je connais
un peu regardé différentes chaînes
centrale principale de la télévision
russe on ne parle que d'une opération
spéciale visons le dundas on ne parle
pas des chars acharif on ne parle pas de
chars aux environs de kiev on ne parle
pas de destruction et dans le dernier
talk show que j'ai regardé juste hier
soir c'est un des grands clubs dans dix
du régime qui s'appelle blaise mirceau
soloviov
il avait un ukrainien
une sorte de souffre douleur sur lequel
donc tout le monde
faisait des invectives et on les donnait
pas la parole juste jusqu'à la fin ce
lieu à donner la parole en dernier et
l'autre il dit mais qu'est ce que vous
faites ça n'a rien à voir avec le débat
ce pour quoi vous bombardez kharkiv
pourquoi il ya des chars à katyn
les autres lui dise mais c'est de la
propagande craignait n'y a pas de char à
karim mais il ya des bâtiments détruits
on a vu les images ah mais c'est la
retirer ou ukrainiennes qui tirent d'un
quartier sur l'autre pour provoquer la
panique et pour nous accuser nos soldats
russes ne faut jamais au grand jamais
une chose comme ça voyez donc toute
l'image
et totalement déformés d'une part et on
parle même pas on parle pas de la guerre
c'est une opération spéciale tout comme
d'ailleurs la deuxième guerre de
tchétchénie
et vous souvenez tous des images de
grozny totalement bombardé comme dresde
à la seconde pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale ça s'appelait opération
antiterroriste donc pas de déclaration
de guerre
le molière est interdit d' usage en
russie simplement les indications ont
été données de ne pas utiliser le mot de
guerre et si dans une guerre il ya des
règles quand même intérêt vous savez il
ya des conventions guesnier qui gère
tout ça dans une opération spéciale et
n'y a rien du tout évidemment jean yves
le conte vous étiez vous le disiez en
ukraine y a il ya peu de jours est ce
que vous êtes surpris par le président
vladimir zelensky
étonnamment non
dans la mesure où il est révélateur de
la résolution du peuple
alors c'est vrai qu'il a pu être
étonnant quand il a été élu et que de
comics il est devenu chef de l'état qui
a pu prendre les manettes et on le voit
effectivement qui tient les chaînes de
commandement peut-être mieux que de
l'autre côté
mais il ne fait qu'être le révélateur de
l'art de la résolution de l'ensemble du
peuple ukrainien
ddd des amis je peux connaître kiseki
qui m'ont dit mais de toute façon depuis
2014 sera de toute façon c'est ont et
qu'ils savaient que peut-être un jour
ils devraient se défendre la population
est prête
et ça finalement il n'en n'est que le
révélateur mais s'était fait tilt il est
effectivement étonnant dans sa capacité
à apporter son peuple à laetitia vous
avez écrit sur ces personnages qui
venait d'un autre univers que la
politique qui ont pris le pouvoir un peu
partout en europe et dans le monde lag
et qui ont été élus à la tentation du
cloud c'est le livre de le type de
l'autre livre aujourd'hui encore on
parle de zelensky à l'une de ces vidéos
a marqué l'actualité oui parce qu'il a
compris et je crois qu'il le sait très
bien que les médias russes sont
complètement muselé je rappelle juste
que ce soir échos de moscou et la webtv
oreilles ont été tout simplement
interdite c'était deux seuls médias
indépendants et encore novaïa gazeta qui
qui est encore limitée que novaïa gazeta
écrit guerre par exemple sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est censuré donc ça il le sait
très bien et c'est là ce qui joue
l'opposition des opinions publiques et
lui parle bien sûr à son opinion
publique mais surtout à l'opinion
publique occidentale et là il était en
visioconférence face au parlement
européen et il a marqué la journée
regarder
ou l'annulation
ne nous laissez pas gibier prouvez long
que sont sept européens
pensent il a le meilleur
ventre l'obscurité gloire à l'ukraine
cette standing ovation au parlement qui
semble interminable et puis lui fini
avec le poing levé et un sourire parce
qu'il sait que les images les signaux et
les symboles marque l'histoire
aujourd'hui d'autant plus qu'ils sont
multi rediffusé il sait qu'il va être
multiplié au diffusée sur les canaux
occidentaux et qu' il imprime les
opinions publiques donc il joue
volodymyr et l'ins qui la carte qu'il
connaît par coeur celle de la
communication est il d'ailleurs il
communique beaucoup sur les réseaux
sociaux dès les premières heures de la
masure russe il a pris facebook et il a
communiqué constamment sur facebook pour
s'en occuper alors effectivement vous le
dis il maîtrise les codes et pour cause
un vous l'avez vous fait il était
producteur acteur humoriste donc c'est
ça il sort deux ennemis son parcours et
ce quoi elle ment sidérant moi c'est
vrai que je me suis penché longuement et
il était humoriste on lit souvent mais
était producteur d'une
présidence grosse boîte de prod de télé
audiovisuel il connaît toutes les
ficelles du métier et il était le héros
d'une série le serviteur du peuple il
avait pris le nom de cette série pour se
lancer en politique
il a appelé son parti politique de ce
nom le serviteur du peuple et il a été
lancé en campagne campagne éclair 1 3
mois avant le premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle il a joué constamment sur
le mélange des genres entre son
personnage de fiction et son et son
personnage réel de candidats à
l'élection présidentielle son personnage
de fiction qui menait une lutte sans
merci contre la corruption
et quand on lui demandait mais vous êtes
qui finalement vous êtes le candidat ou
vous êtes le héros il disait bon quel
est le quelle est la question à quoi ça
sert de répondre à cette question
qu'est-ce que ça importe finalement la
réponse à cette question est donc il a
réussi à retourner l'opinion publique il
a gagné avec 72 % des voix il est devenu
influenceurs sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est pour ça qu'il s'en sert très bien
et si vous voulez avoir une idée de ce
qu'est cette série qui a été diffusé
pendant la campagne présidentielle je
mets 6 elle est rediffusée en ce moment
sur arte
le sérieux du paf et le regarder en
russe sous titré brusselmans moment
étonnamment quand en campagne
présidentielle quand on lui demande à
quel est votre programme regardé ma
série
et il est d'autant plus dangereux pour
ça c'est qu'il sait maîtriser les codes
de communication vis-à-vis des russes
fans et cancel oui oui c'est ça je moi
je suis extrêmement sceptique sur la
capacité du soft power et notamment de
la communication ainsi que de
l'épaisseur où la dimension culturelle
dans l'est dans les conflits à la fin
des fins ce sont les f-35 et les canons
qui l'emportent malheureusement mais
c'est comme ça en revanche là on a
affaire à quelque chose d'assez nouveau
d'abord poutine la communication de
poutine et simplement à l'us sinequa ces
derniers disent courant de ces animaux à
dix dernières semaines sont nommés hier
son nom crédible même pour les russes
mais je parle sous notre contrôle
considérez zelensky d'origine juive qui
a été élu démocratiquement avec le score
époustouflant vous rappelez il ya un
instant et qui ne cherchent évidemment
pas à croquer quoi que ce soit la russie
c'est ridicule donc n'hésitez ce
bonhomme est sérieux et ridicule par
ailleurs outre cette brutalisation
outrancière de poutine qui le sert
effectivement par définition il maîtrise
parfaitement le russe autrement dit il
nous dit des choses à nous il très bien
sauf que ni vous ni moi n'allons allait
prendre un fusil demain pour mourir pour
kiev en revanche lorsqu'ils s'adressent
directement à la population russe
lorsqu'il s'adresse directement aux
soldats russes dont on voit bien pour
certains régimes en tout cas la très
faible motivation là on a quelque chose
de relativement nouveau il leur dit
faisait les armes qu absolument alors il
leur demande il est simple ils les
implants pas il donne une véritable une
manière très digne de s'adresser à eux
mais il leur est point que
l'incompréhension totale qui qui déjà de
caractérise beaucoup de soldats russes
et une partie de l'opinion ils ont du
coup il a réussi à renverser le lait les
rares est tous allés j'allais dire en
termes d'opinion publique les rares
relais dont pouvait encore disposer dont
certains malheureusement en france
vladimir poutine mais il ya un élément
vous que vous ne signalait pas là c'est
quand même l'impact de ces discours sur
sa population sur les ukrainiens eux
mêmes c'est pas notre capacité de
résistance vous avez raison mais l'ajout
rejoint au fond c'est la traduction est
l'illustration d'une conscience
nationale qui elle aussi a été
manifestement sous-estimé ou mésestimé
plaque pas par par vladimir poutine et
une conscience nationale ça se traduit
notamment dans l'adversité galia
ackerman dans on a on a peut-être été
surpris je sais je sais plus et et yahia
deux ou trois jours on s'y perd un peu
mais cet appel à fabriquer des cocktails
molotov ça semblait un peu dérisoire par
rapport aux chars russes mais ça fait
référence aussi à l'histoire des
ukrainiens et à l'histoire de la seconde
guerre mondiale dans leur résistance
face aux 9 face aux nazis justement
absolument d'une part les ukrainiens ont
très brillamment
combattu dans les rangs de l'armée rouge
il ya 8 au 9 millions d'ukrainiens qui
ont péri pendant la seconde guerre
mondiale mais également ils ont
longtemps résisté en ukraine occidentale
parce que là c'est c'est une autre
histoire c'est une partie qui a été
annexé par staline en vertu des en tout
cas ils secret du pacte molotov
ribbentrop
qui ensuite ont été occupées comme tout
le reste de l'est de l'ukraine par les
allemands et qui ont été libérés en 44
et donc de nouveaux sont retrouvés sous
contrôle soviétique
or ce sont des territoires qui ont fait
partie de l'empiré austro hongrois ou y
avait une promotion c'était la politique
de l'autriche hongrie la promotion de la
culture
locale pour chaque peuple
c'était un empire
assez exemplaire
et donc pour l'occupation soviétique
avec des déportations de la population
avec des gens au goulag
physique et c'est rare c'était quelque
chose d'intolérable et bien les ya eu un
moment partisans qui s'est prolongée
jusqu'à
1956 et la haine de l'ukraine est aussi
dû à ce phénomène parce que pendant ces
deux années ils ont quand même tué ses
partisans trente mille chefs locaux de
partie des dignitaires du parti des
services secrets et des militaires donc
la
mls elle est très très profondes et
anciennes
et je dois dire que les ukrainiens ils
ont aussi montré de grandes capacités de
se battre quand leur armée était
totalement désorganisé pendant la
période ianoukovitch c'était la
débandade je pense que il y avait même
un probablement d
des forces qui devrait pour l'affaiblir
cette armée est néanmoins bon la crimée
a été annexé pratiquement sans
résistance
mais dans le débat c'est il ya eu des
combats très acharné et par exemple le
combat de l'aéroport de donetsk qui a
résisté pendant une année
face à un adversaire
bien supérieur c'est quelque chose d
louis et on peut imaginer que ça se
répète en ce moment et dans les jours
voire les semaines à venir je vous
l'avais promis on va écouter plusieurs
fois et encore une fois volodymyr
zelensky qui lance cet appel à l'europe
s'était toujours devant les députés
européens
on écoute le président ukrainien
je suis heureux que nous ayons réussi à
vous réunir tous aujourd'hui les pays de
l'ue ce mais je ne savais pas que ce
serait un tel prix et c'est une tragédie
pour moi une tragédie pour chaque
ukrainien une tragédie pour notre état
notre peuple est très très motivés nous
nous battons pour nos droits pour nos
libertés pour nos vies et maintenant
nous nous battons pour notre survie
c'est quand même genre yves lecompte une
analyse très juste quoi il a fallu cette
crise pour pour souder l'europe
absolument et il ya quelque chose qu'il
ne dit pas c'est qu'il se bat pour nous
pour les valeurs de la sq si l'ukraine
tombe
c'est finalement la fin d'un monde
c'est la fin de la construction de
l'union européenne
c'est la fin de la capacité du droit
international de 2,2
[Musique]
de réguler les relations entre les états
c'est définitivement on y sent est
définitivement terminée de toutes les
efforts en termes de produits de lutte
contre la prolifération nucléaire
et en ce qui concerne l'europe
nous savons que les ce que les fables de
la dîmière poutine bon demain visait la
lettonie la moldavie et c'est alors
parti aujourd'hui c'est un combat que
malheureusement compte tenu de la
dissuasion nucléaire nous ne pouvons pas
mener
mais notre avenir dépend de la capacité
de l'ukraine de rêver je vous donne la
parole mais je cite florence parly qui
était qui était devant le l'assemblée
puis le sénat dans le cadre de cette
journée de débats parlementaires la
ministre la défense soit l'europe fait
face soit elles s'effacent est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec cette idée
fréquence est complètement peu paris
s'échiner le plus précisément le tandem
macron le drian ne s'échine depuis cinq
ans maintenant à tenter de convaincre
les chancelleries européennes qu'il faut
non pas bail passé et fall de passer
outre l'otan ou cassés l'otan ce que
vous le faire entre parenthèses stroem
pas les européens trouvent lui-même mais
nous accorder une autonomie stratégique
supplémentaire aujourd'hui lui créer une
autonomie traduite par rapport à
washington et en guise de dissuasion
face à à moscou et pourquoi pas à pékin
parce que ce que vous dites est d'autant
plus juste que non seulement les
européens aujourd'hui on est à craindre
d'une dinde un échec si nous ne sommes
pas assez uni et est puissant et à
nouveau dissuasif une face à poutine
mais imaginez aujourd'hui ce qu'on est
en train se sont en train de penser les
taïwanais imaginez ce que pensent
aujourd'hui les sud coréens les japonais
les philippins et une grande partie du
monde indo pacifique si l'occident pour
faire pour faire recours et l'otan en
particulier ne ne parvient pas à
dissuader suffisamment poutine bien il a
c'est trop tard il est entré enfin pour
l'instant pays ne il a choisi d'entrer
que sur une partie du cred s'il va
jusqu'au bout autrement dit si on n'a
pas réussi par des sanctions économiques
financières ou par une dissuasion
stratégique et militaire à l'en empêcher
mais vous comprenez bien que les chinois
vont s'engouffrer dans la brèche d'une
manière ou d'une autre même si en
l'occurrence là ils ne sont pas
favorables ou booba ou modérément
favorable on va dire ça comme ça même
s'ils sont une neutralité bienveillante
vis-à-vis de poutine que va-t-il se
passer en termes de crédibilité
occidental à taiwan et dans la dos
pacifique donc ce qui se joue là qu'elle
fait je vous rejoins tout à fait ce
c'est aussi une grande partie oui c'est
ça des delà de l'exercice et des modes
de rapport de force dont les relations
internationales de manière générale mais
si vous permettez je dirais même autre
chose c'est qu'aujourd'hui la chine est
capable parce que pour faire ce qu'ils
faisaient du côté de l'europe la russie
se comporte en vassal absolu de la chine
par conséquent aujourd'hui un pays qui
est capable de siffler la fin de la
récréation russe
c'est la chine
est d'accord avec cette idée kelly
ackermann je pense que c'est vrai parce
que nous l'avons vu quand
monsieur tout cas hier le président du
kazakhstan a demandé le tess est ce donc
là
conseil de sécurité non non non
l'organisation de traité de sécurité
collective donc six pays de l'ex urss
d'intervenir dans son pays pour mater
une sorte de révolution populaire
il semblait à tout le monde moi compris
d'ailleurs que les troupes russes
allaient rester et puis quelques jours
après cette cette entrée de troupes
on annonce à la télévision bon bain les
troupes ont accompli leur tâche il
rentre à la maison et donc la rumeur
court mais je ne peux pas vous le
prouver il n'y a pas de documents
associés tels que c'est si jim beam qui
a demandé à monsieur poutine de de
procéder à la retraite de ces trop
d'évacuer les troupes je pense que c'est
c'est assez logique parce que kazakhstan
il est beau à être un peu vassaliser par
la russie mais il est aussi un peu
vassaliser par la chine qui a fait des
investissements énormes et qui est donc
apparemment n'a pas voulu que la russie
acquiert une présence très intéressant
maintenant que là bas on parle souvent
de la chine depuis le début de sa
semaine jamais oublier la chine dans
l'analyse de ce qui se passe en ce
moment très dur et c'est juste c'est une
hypothèse très intéressante l'autre
hypothèse est exactement antinomiques
monsieur poutine a dit à la chine le
kazakhstan c'est votre route de la soie
par laquelle vous ne pouvez pas les
quais qui est incontournable sur le plan
terrestre en tout cas vous ne la
vassalité pas comme vous vassaliser
l'afrique j'envoie - des troupes quand
j'ai envie d envoyer ça c'est le site
une autre hypothèse est une relecture et
si notre lecture et je crois davantage à
cette deuxième hypothèse est l'épée
parlera par ailleurs les chinois peuvent
cesser en tout cas peuvent exercer de
vraie pression ça c'est juste sur sur
poutine notamment du point de vue des
sanctions occidentales ils sont capables
aujourd'hui contrairement à ce qui ce
prêt à ce qui prévalait en 2014 de deux
paliers de compenser dans une certaine
mesure cela pour les sensations à
prudent pour l'instant ils sont issues
essentiellement attentiste et puis et
puis l'ukraine d'un état souverain donc
ça c'est pour la chine est extrêmement
embêtant mais attention si on obtient si
on cherche et on obtient de la chine
pressions qui seraient déterminantes sur
poutine ils vont nous le faire payer il
y aura un coût il y aura nécessairement
un coût et ce coût ce sera les tibétains
les we go et éventuellement taiwan c'est
les chinois et ça c'est une leçon
multiséculaire film donne à leur
exercice du pouvoir et des relations
internationales et des rapports de force
ne se fait pas prioritairement par les
armes ça c'était la voix occidentale et
russe les deux au sein a eu d'abord ont
frappé ensuite en discuter
éventuellement et parfois ont colonisé
les chinois n'ont eux ils manipulent
toute la palette est toute une série de
levier un dispositif de levier et en
dernier ressort il utilise les armements
les taux merci beaucoup merci à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je rappelle
le titre de vos livres galia ackerman le
régiment immortel la guerre sacrée de
poutine
c'est aux éditions premier parallèle et
frédéric encel votre livre qui sort ce
mercredi les voies de la puissance aux
éditions odile jacob merci encore merci
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat